c'est délicat parce qu'une instruction
parce qu'en disant ça est de mon point
de vue je dis oui parce qu'elle donne
vraiment son point de vue à la question
c'est une femme de sincérité déjà
question sélest'art doivent-elles point
de position à dakota et la question vous
avez posées donc j'ai répondu
c'est pas moi c'est très compliqué parce
que l'instruction est en cours mais
néanmoins je trouve que si elle le
ressens comme ça et elle n'entre pas
dans le détail de la faire c'est très
bien de donner son point de vue bravo à
elle alors vous pensez vous pensez
vraiment qu'ils doivent pas moi je pense
pas je pense pas que tout le monde doit
donner son avis parce que d'abord il ya
une enquête qui est là on sait pas ce
qui s'est passé ça avance j'aimerais à
titre personnel que ça avance beaucoup
beaucoup plus vite parce que là on est
en train de tuer la carrière de
quelqu'un est peut-être la jeune femme
aussi il faudrait qu'on l'entende quand
c'est pas par exemple qu'on signe vite
sur macron le lendemain c'est réglé là
on pourrait peut-être accélérer les
choses et dire ça commence à prendre
beaucoup d'ampleur est ce que
c'est une instruction
relative dont la course avec qui
je suis d'accord c'est détourné il faut
lui rentrer la ville à la fois il faut
qu'ils regardent ce qui s'était passé 1
mais ces noms bien de longue haleine la
justice a devrait pas trancher quand il
incombe maintenant l'entente raymond fau
longtemps
iconique cela je laisse du temps je
laisse du temps il n'y a pas de problème
et moi je suis d'accord avec elle s'ils
aiment se sont ressentis de se mettre
dans la position de la victime à la
raison se sont ressentis elle parle
c'est courageux de parler c'est son
choix à la et c'est ce qu'elle pense
donc voilà je vois même si elle n'arrive
pas
la question la question de les résumer
vous êtes tard et la question s'était
donné leur opinion mais oui a dit non tu
viens de dire oui oui
il rentre en dépréciant
[Applaudissements]
oui encore
c'est une force qui a dit que des
tableaux la victime prime chez moi est
en fait un look était apparemment elle
vraiment le courage de dire ce que les
trois quarts à pluri des acteurs pensent
tout bas beaucoup d'acteurs en coulisses
en fermant qui ne soutiennent pas les
habitants qui soutiennent la victime
présumée dans cette histoire et vous
savez qu'ary abittan été écarté de la
promotion du film en allant sur la vie
de bernard qui au départ 'ainsi je ne
sais pas ce qui s'est passé bernard
montiel mais en tout cas je défends mon
ami c'est vrai que bernard il s'effrite
il a droit de le faire aussi mais
adhérer habitants a été mise à l'écart
de la promotion du film on a tout mis
sur le dos de la production apparemment
beaucoup d'acteurs ne voulait pas non
plus être associé avec lui et à son
image pendant cette période compliquée
alors machin vous dites non bagués et
non parce qu'effectivement je trouve que
c'est déjà très difficile pour lui et je
prouve qu'ils pourraient y avoir il est
fait de solidarité du métier d'autant
qu'ils aient l'instruction en cours a
presque compensé bon solidarité
même pas s'exprimer cyril lui donne son
point de vue jeudi zack wright pas
compris ma position ni pour
l'indépendance
et après je rejoins après je rejoins
pour le court est bon c'est vrai que ce
qu'elle dit la séquelle être tendance ap
a donné voilà de l'écho à la victime
mais mise à part ça sent que vous avez
du métier c'est pas très cool pour lui
ben ali mais ce qu'est ce que dit
claudia tagbo s'est elle dit en gros a
priori je dis aux victimes on vous
entend on vous écoute on vous croit et
après il se prononce pas sur le fond de
la faire et c'est en ça que moi je dis
voilà il faut pas se prononcer sur le
fond des affaires y'a pas à croire ou
pas croire il ya la justice elle passe
et ensuite en fonction ce que tu diras
la justice on écoute la laine est prévue
il faut rappeler qu'elle dit baisse à
d'elle-même elle répond à une interview
donc voilà le courage de le dire et si
elle a répondu on dirait qu'il fait de
la langue de bois personne s'exprime là
au moins le courage de donner son
opinion si moi je pense qu'elle n'a pas
donné son avis n a pas choisi un camp
voilà le message que je ressens juste le
message d'une femme qui dit bah écouter
la parole de la victime prime mais voilà
on attend on attend de voir mais
sûrement elle a pas pris parti